hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Lauren
God excuse the shadow over the face and
let the best of DP terrible lighting
we're gonna watch the trailer for the
houses October built what is that it's a
horror no don't know anything about I
refuse well we're gonna watch a trailer
I hate scary thing I hate scary movies
I hate haunted houses I hate things that
are scary like I was watching The
Walking Dead the other day which I guess
is kind of scary but it's like too scary
for me no I was like I can't watch this
by myself I have like this pillow on it
I bet I bet my hands were like white cuz
I was clutching this pillow so tightly
you're probably used to clutching things
tightly though what it's a dick Joe yeah
but we you wouldn't want to clutch that
tightly
well it depends on how hard the guy
wants you to touch it right I don't
think that you want me to clench it so
hard that my fists are white you never
know
nearly 25 haunted attractions open
that's gonna do you care if we ask you
some questions I'm with all this group
of people and we're trying to find
something extreme we got it it's in
Louisiana this year we don't have an
address
we go home tomorrow okay that wasn't the
scariest trailer I can handle that it's
a cool title it's a very interesting
concept yeah but I would rather I would
rather see a movie that actually takes
place during the Haunted mazes and stuff
like that what [ __ ] go wrong there
instead of them leaving and go in an RV
and stuff and going out in the middle of
nowhere I'd rather see you like a bag
actual [ __ ] go down and like people
dying like that's when I was really
hooked
but once they left thing on the RV I was
like oh there have been things like that
already though that have been made I
mean I don't know a lot about horror
movies but I feel like there have been
movies that have been made about like
haunted houses that are like actually oh
yeah sure so like this is new I feel
like it's new in it it's new and in a
sense of how it's like I mean they found
footage genres getting kind of old to me
yeah I'm sure it is for a lot of people
in terms of this I mean it looks like it
could be a little different but it
doesn't look that scary surprisingly
yeah like there are a lot of commercials
on TV when they're not like even the
full trailer that are scary like yeah
like I am watching like Modern Family
and then a stupid commercial comes on
I'm like this was okay I kept thinking
that something was gonna like just
badass and gonna happen didn't happen no
whole trailer yeah I mean the makeup
looks creepy I guess other than that
it's like think about its execution
feels too familiar I mean maybe they're
like building a lot of suspense I'm just
sick of that shot of like cameraman
falls over the camera maybe it'll be
good cool title cool concept but as far
as his trailers promoting it I I could
honestly care less it's a lot I feel
like they needed that last clip you know
it's like really really quiet and then
it shows all the people's legs with the
way mm-hmm I feel like that's that clip
should have been something more shocking
and that would have nothing at the end
of the trailer but it'd be really cool
I mean are we supposed to be guessing
the whole time like is this a real
haunting or the people just [ __ ] with
him is that what we're supposed to be
doing I don't know well Lauren you
should have these answers I don't have
any things I told you I hate horror
movies I refuse to watch work I haven't
even seen jaws because I think that
would be too scary it is pretty scary
cool subscribe yeah subscribe for the
real rejects and you could subscribe to
Lauren's channel yeah there we go
we mentioned the subscribe buttons we
did what youtubers have to do ok GB
gaming GB gaming can have a shout out
please Ryan okay GB gaming stands for
Greg's balls gaming is that a game
hunter is it are your balls gaming the
balls our game it's named after this
famous guy named Greg Alba ok who has
these ginormous balls okay and he's able
to control them by playing with the
controller with just his two testicles
actually he has three testicles
yeah I keep mentioning this Greg Aiello
is that he's got big balls and stuff
apparently I hear ya does me you want
big balls sure you do
no that would be weird like what are you
gonna do with those you produce more
sperm nobody wants that you don't talk
bad about Greg's three testicles okay
Susie like triple the sperm any has huge
balls so he's making like quadruple
e-enough yeah
so he's a very happy guy so how was that
happy what if you guys these huge balls
that he has a tiny penis how do you know
that about great I don't know I guess
I'm really good at guessing people's
penises size once I meet them I don't
know probably interesting superpower
that would be should become like a
fortune teller but for penises yeah
drove the hard wash you guys sorry wash
drove barred was you started off with
saying you guys suck now that I got your
attention may I have a shout-out lol you
guys are awesome that's lame that's
[ __ ] up dude you suck suck exclamation
exclamation exclamation exclamation
exclamation you suck big fat balls that
are backed up with a tiny penis you suck
Greg's balls and dick GB gaming you and
GB gaming he's always like Oh drugs suck
my balls or whatever your name is I
don't know what you are
that sounds like you could be like
Middle Eastern yeah some Middle Eastern
guy Middle East they're the reason we
are at war don't put that in the video
why isn't that why we're at war didn't
they do something yeah I don't follow
politics okay we're there because we
have a right to be there pay we're there
his America does whatever would walk
when there's problems in the world
America likes to go in there a fix it so
that's what we're doing right yeah
America's fixing everything I say throw
more troops in there go and find drove
drove we'll fix it
bring him to me Oh
I wonder how many people I just piss the
Rasta here yo real give me a shout-out
please sure real I'll be more than happy
to give you a shout-out right after I
turn my phone off I mean not real what's
the name for us Faraz for now he's
definitely Middle Eastern for Rasta here
we have a lot of Middle Eastern
subscribers cool guys you know I'm a big
fan of Middle Eastern people I'm not
racist at all I'm not you go into any
7-eleven and I treat all those middle
Easterns with a lot of respect I do I do
I'm making a movie about what it's like
in the life of Iraq and the main
characters of Middle Eastern it's about
one Middle Eastern taking on about 90%
of the other characters or terrorists
and it's about this one Middle Eastern
who's like I will not be a terrorist why
are you lying that was [ __ ] up I
didn't piss off too many people but I
probably did frogs
I'm sure you're a good guy I know you're
not a terrorist I don't know he does
subscribe to your channel it might be a
terrorist might be who knows maybe maybe
al Qaeda is somehow infiltrating my
channel and I have to stop them before
it's too late
that's it for shoutouts you guys
subscribe I hope you enjoyed bye mm-hmm
peace in Iraq or war if you're for it